now from the abraham lincoln institute's
fifth annual symposium history professor
ronald white junior author of Lincoln's
greatest speech it's a close reading of
the speech Abraham Lincoln gave in 1865
at his second inauguration it's just
under an hour I thank you Scott we have
a very full program this afternoon so of
necessity our introductions of the
speakers will be somewhat shorter than
this morning but that is no means a
reflection on the excellence of our
speakers this afternoon
in fact in looking over his impressive
and I might even say solemn resume in
preparation for introducing our next
speaker the feeling came over me that I
perhaps should begin with prayer instead
let me begin with another time-tested
religious practice by taking up and
offering
not really but figuratively as treasurer
of the Abraham Lincoln Institute let me
appeal to you good people to dig deeply
into your pockets and make a generous
tax-deductible contribution to permit us
to bring you continue to bring you the
Word of God I mean uh the word of
Lincoln sorry for our viewing audience
out there in cyberspace you can go to
our website Lincoln - dot o-r-g Lincoln
- org to learn oh yes I'm sorry Lincoln
- Institute dot o-- r-- g-- let me
repeat that Lincoln - Institute Oh RG to
learn how where our mailing address is
to send us a donation you'll feel better
for it and we will bless you for it but
now back to my sermon I mean I mean
introduction Ronald C white jr.
currently is professor of church history
at San Francisco Theological Seminary
where he was Dean and vice president for
academic affairs from 1996 through 2001
he has also taught at Princeton
Theological Seminary Fuller Theological
Seminary and the school of theology at
Claremont - my somewhat irreverent mind
that's an awful lot of theology I must
tell you though that and meeting a mr. Y
for the first time this morning he
assured me that he is a historian not a
theologian evidently that's been a lot
of theology for Dean white also he
doesn't seem to be able to hold a job
for very long
his resume lists by my count 19
different positions and a 38 year career
but to be fair several of the positions
were at the same institution and some
were held concurrently including it one
interesting combination the early 1970
when he was a professor of American
Studies and chaplain at
writer college I I just I hope for his
students sake he was able to keep
separate office hours and for his sake
also I'm sure but to close on a more
serious note Dean White has written
widely and thoughtfully on the religious
dimension of American history social and
racial reform and the social gospel
his most recent book Lincoln's greatest
speech the second inaugural was
published earlier this year by Simon &
Schuster the second inaugural he writes
was Lincoln's last will and testament to
the nation and concurring with that
benediction I yield the pulpit I mean
the podium to our next speaker
as we begin I want to be certain that
everyone has the text of the second
inaugural in their hands if you don't
maybe you could put up your hands and
we'll be sure to get a text to you some
hands are going up so if we can get that
text to people I'd like to have it in
your hands I'm deeply honored at the
invitation to be speaking with you this
afternoon and I want to say a special
tribute to John Sellars the president of
this organization as I refer to John and
my acknowledgments the point man at the
Library of Congress John by his simple
presence opened up to me by telephone by
cajoling a person that many people had
not known before in terms of Lincoln
scholarship and I'm deeply grateful to
John for all that he has done in that
same spirit every day as I worked on the
second inaugural
I found myself conscious that I was
standing on the shoulders of Lincoln
scholars past and present
I felt humbled as one does in the
western United States when one is
following the trail of eminent pioneers
and so if I at times deviate from those
trails perhaps try to cut a fresh trail
it is always with appreciation of those
who have done such solid work in this
field Abraham Lincoln considered the
second inaugural to be his greatest
speech 11 days after offering it he
replied to a congressional etter I
expect the better the latter to wear as
well perhaps better than anything I have
produced but then he went on to add but
I believe it is not immediately popular
hold that thought
I'm going to come back in about 25 or 30
minutes and ask you your opinion as to
why if Lincoln thought this was his
greatest speech he perceived that it was
not immediately popular in speaking
about Linc
in recent weeks mostly in the West I've
been asking the question how many of you
have seen and read the second inaugural
at the Lincoln Memorial I'm sure if I
asked that question in this audience
that every hand would go up and I've
asked people for their experience their
emotion in being there at the second at
the Lincoln Memorial you recall even
though it's close to us that we rise on
those steps we see that majestic statue
of Lincoln if you turn to the left you
see the Gettysburg Address carved in
Indiana limestone on the south wall if
you turn to the right you see the second
inaugural three panels carved on the
north wall what some of you be willing
to say what are your experiences a few
weeks ago or a few years ago as you have
visited the Lincoln Memorial tell me
what your experiences are I can repeat
it for us others yes we went to the
Lincoln Memorial we after September 11
and reading the last paragraph with
malice towards none
I think Lincoln was saying you know we
have to be careful do we
Benj our anger towards she suggests that
going to see the Lincoln Memorial in the
second inaugural after September 11 a
week after that it causes us to pause as
we think about how are we going to
respond to those who are perhaps viewed
as our enemies other responses hard to
see sometimes with the bright lights but
I'd like to get some more responses yes
sir please do we need to say my people
were
they weren't really the same Bible and
at the time the second inaugural is
delivered as I've asked that question
I've had people respond with words such
as aw wonder amazement yesterday
afternoon my wife and I wandered over
again to the Lincoln Memorial and walked
up those steps and stood there in
preparation for today just to get a
sense I observed when I was there the
sort of facial expressions of people I
noted that I'd never done this before I
noted that most of the people were there
observing the Gettysburg Address far
fewer people were reading the second
inaugural part of what I'm suggesting is
that the second inaugural has lived
under the shadow of the Gettysburg
Address we all know something about that
address of the epic battle that took
place July 1 2 3 1863 of the hasty
preparations to have a dedication
ceremony in November I'm sure most of us
know that Edward Everett was the invited
speaker and that he went on for more
than two hours that Lincoln spoke for
only two and a half minutes Garry wills
has attempted to set us straight on did
he write it on the flap of an envelope
when did he write it but all of that
kind of contributes doesn't it to our
amazement and engagement with the
Gettysburg Address I want to suggest
here this afternoon that the second
inaugural has an equally dramatic
context that somehow has been lost to us
we don't visit the second inaugural in
the way that today millions of visitors
visit the Gettysburg Address well we do
visit the Lincoln Memorial but it
doesn't quite have the same sense about
it
think for a moment a nation has just
conducted an election while it is
involved in a civil war almost
unprecedented
the nation is aware we have forgotten
that this is the first re-election of a
president in 32 years in a nation that
is only 76 years old I'm not sure if I
asked the extra credit question that you
could answer who are the presidents in
the 1840s and 1850s Walt Whitman
wrote a draft of a dress filled with
epithets about those who had been
presidents before Lincoln and he looked
forward off farther into the future for
an 18th president who would one day set
the nation's wrongs aright the nation
was filled if you read the newspapers as
I did every single day the front page is
filled with the exploits and the
victories of Grant and Sherman in the
northern commanders we have forgotten
that Lincoln's first words at this
second appearing what an amazing
sentence it is not four score and seven
years ago it's not the way he begins his
other addresses but he didn't expect to
appear in August of 1864 the Republican
National Committee convened in the Astor
Hotel in New York City they communicated
their results to Lincoln at the White
House they told him that today he would
lose Illinois by 50,000 votes there was
no possibility of winning Pennsylvania
he would be soundly defeated in New York
State and then Lincoln took this
information and on August 23rd he went
to his cabinet he had written out a memo
he didn't let them see the memo but they
signed the back of the envelope in which
the memo was contained and it said in
these words when we are defeated for
re-election it will be our duty to
cooperate with a new president that the
nation might succeed take this address
with in your hands the words that are
most familiar to all of us are the last
paragraph if you turn to the second page
I found myself about three weeks ago
appearing in a coffeehouse in Berkeley
California I didn't have my rings in my
pocket and the speaker in the first hour
was speaking on advanced sex tips for
girls it was a wonderful event filled
with irreverent music and all sorts of
things and I thought how in the world
are we going to transition to Lincoln
and as I sat there with a live studio
audience and this is broadcast on FM
around the United States my hosts
stunned me by saying dr. white would you
be willing to read the entire
second inaugural address well I'm making
the point that Lincoln wrote for the ear
most people today write for the eye and
we need to hear these words I suggest at
the beginning of my book that we need to
say these words out loud I was in
Springfield several weeks ago to sign my
book in the restored old Capitol
building and the next day I went for the
first time I must admit to the Lincoln
Herndon law offices
I knew this from reading about it but
now I heard it from the guide that his
Lincoln would come into the law office
in the morning he drove his partner
Willie Herndon just to oblivion by
sitting down spreading out on the couch
and reading aloud we teach our children
to read to themselves Lincoln had a
sense for the sound of words listen to
the last paragraph with malice toward
none with charity for all with firmness
in the right as God gives us to see the
right let us strive on to finish the
work we are in to bind up the nation's
wounds to care for him who shall have
borne the battle and for his widow and
his orphan to do all which may achieve
and cherish a just and a lasting peace
among ourselves and with all nations now
I've just broken the rule that I'm
trying to put forward in my book my
complaint is that that particular
paragraph has been excerpted and put in
a American history textbooks and in
books of documents totally ripped away
from the three paragraphs that went
before in fact some scholars have gone
so far as to suggest that it has little
meshing with what went before not so it
grows out directly of what Lincoln had
said in the first three paragraphs but
before we're ready to hear these words
would you come with me to Washington in
the first week of March
in 1865 we need to be there with the
crowd to prepare ourselves to hear these
words President Abraham Lincoln had
every reason to be hopeful as March 4
1865 approached the Confederacy was
splintered if not shattered
General William Tecumseh Sherman led
60,000 troops out of Savannah slashing
through South Carolina they wreaked
havoc in the state that had been the
seedbed of secession at the same time
general ulysses s grant was besieging
petersburg 20 miles south of Richmond
despite robert e lee's previous record
for for stalling defeat it was clear
that the badly outnumbered Confederates
could not hold out much longer
everything pointed toward victory
apprehension intruded upon this hopeful
spirit rumors were flying about the
capital that desperate Confederates now
realizing that defeat was imminent would
attempt to abduct or assassinate the
president remember no president had ever
been assassinated two had died in office
Secretary of War Edwin M Stanton took
extraordinary precautions all roads
leading to Washington had been heavily
picketed for some days the problem was
greatly complicated by the prop by the
presence of Confederate deserters twelve
hundred and thirty-nine Confederate
deserters arrived in Washington in the
month of February Stanton posted
sharpshooters on the buildings that
would ring the inaugural ceremonies
plainclothes detectives rolled the city
keeping track of questionable persons
after four years as President Lincoln
could look ahead to four years as a
peace president one of the things that I
want to do in our frame of reference is
to change the reference we see this as
the end of Lincoln's life Lincoln saw
this as the beginning of four years and
probably eight years as president with
no Congress in session until December to
hamper him he would have some free rein
to do some peacemaking on his own
gamblers were even betting that the 16th
president would be inaugurated for a
third term in 1869 the president who had
been battered by critics in Congress and
the press where much of the war was
finally beginning to receive credit for
his leadership many suggesting however
that the stakes were about to get higher
how would Lincoln the successful come
and are in chief in war be able to guide
a reunited nation during what was
beginning to be called reconstruction as
the day for the inauguration drew near
everyone wondered what the president
would say no one seemed to know anything
about the content of Lincoln's second
inaugural speech it was recalled that he
had taken 35 minutes to deliver his
first inaugural how would Lincoln deal
with the questions that were multiplying
would he use his rhetorical skills to
take the hide off his opponents in the
south and the north was the Confederate
States of America to be treated as a
conquered nation how did you demarcate
between the innocent and the guilty
between citizens and soldiers
what would Lincoln say about the slaves
they had been emancipated but what about
the question of suffrage just beneath
this outward merrymaking
lay a different emotion I felt that one
of my tasks it's the second tasks in
Aristotle's treatise on rhetoric was to
attempt to discern the mood of the
audience and I argue that one of
Lincoln's greatest skills was that he
spoke at to a real audience
not an ideal audience and today
political speakers speak to ideal
audiences and not real audiences and
Lincoln tried to understand the mood the
temperament of the audience standing in
front of him that day even though he
knew his words would be printed in all
of the newspapers a weariness of spirit
pervaded the nation the agony of battle
took its soil on families everywhere
many citizens I argue were filled as
much with anger as with hope even the
anticipation of victory could not
compensate for the loss of so many young
men cut down in death or disabled by
horrible wounds just as they were
preparing to harvest the fruits of their
young lives and death and despair
reached into nearly every home the
enormity of the human loss in the Civil
War reaches across time an estimated 600
and 23,000 men died in the Civil War
comparisons with other Wars bring it
home in World War one
the number killed was a hundred and
seventeen thousand in World War two four
hundred and five or four hundred and
seven thousand in the Korean War the
death toll was fifty four thousand in
the war in Vietnam the number of
Americans killed was fifty eight
thousand deaths in the Civil War equaled
the deaths in all other wars put
together
but if World War two had produced the
same proportion of deaths as did the
Civil War
remembering the United States was a
small nation in the 1860s that would
have meant that this generation that
we're now justly honoring would have
suffered 2.5 million casualties in World
War two the loss of so many fathers
husbands brothers sons usurped the joy
and reward of imminent victory
Washington had never seen so many
travelers as converged for Lincoln's
second inaugural trains roared and
smoked over the double tracks of the
Baltimore in Ohio
hotels were overflowing yesterday we
built visited Willard the Willard the
grand five-story hotel it had its cots
in all of its parlors the Metropolitan
and the National were filled the hotels
are literally shelving their guests
reported the correspondence for the New
York Times Lincoln and Johnson clubs
housed more than a thousand visitors
firehouses offered more sleeping spaces
all knew that they were coming to
witness a dramatic event on Friday
morning March 3rd visitors crowded the
streets of the capital in spite of the
inclement weather
nothing could hide the disorder and the
dirt that was everywhere the national
capital barely six decades old remained
an almost City Charles Dickens in his
first visit to Washington in 1842 had
called the American capital quote the
city of magnificent intentions he
described Washington satirically as
quote spacious avenues that begin in
nothing and lead nowhere streets mile
long that only want
homes roads and inhabitants public
buildings that need but a public to be
complete one visitor from Philadelphia
was plainly irked if you want to be
disgusted with a place chosen for the
capital of your country visit it in the
springtime near the close of four days
rain when the frost is beginning to come
out of the ground what other other
objects of interest may attract your
notice the muddy streets and pavements
will scarcely escape you Washington
which had been transformed into an armed
camp at the beginning of the war had now
become a gigantic hospital white
buildings and tents dotted the city many
of the 40 or so hospitals were simply
makeshift wooden sheds all were crowded
often hundreds sometimes thousands of
soldiers lay in a bin adjoining beds the
staggering number of wounded could not
be confined to hospitals the sick and
wounded could be found in hotels
warehouses schools
paternal lodges churches vied with each
other as makeshift hospitals the thing
it startled me as I tried to understand
the scene to which Lincoln addressed was
this reality their wounds marked the
soldiers who came in large numbers to
Lincoln's second inauguration amputation
had become the trademark of Civil War
surgery
according to federal records three out
of four operations were amputations too
often the surgery had to be repeated
again many visitors professed shock at
the sight of so many young men with
amputated legs and arms March 4 dawned
with incessant rain streets boozing with
soft mud described by locals as black
plaster greeted visitors the Corps of
Engineers surveyed the scene to
determine the practicality of laying
pontoons on Pennsylvania Avenue from the
capital of the White House they found
the bottom too unstable to hold the
anchors of the needed boats during the
early morning hours winds whipped
through the city uprooting trees in the
early morning fog continued
to hang over the city as the crowd began
arriving at the east entrance of the
Capitol carriages were in great demand
premium prices were being offered for a
ride to the capital police estimates
placed the crowd between 30 and 40
thousand the Philadelphia Inquirer
reported that the arriving throng was
present quote enforced sufficient to
have struck terror into the heart of
Lee's army had the umbrellas been
muskets but I enjoyed doing in my
research was trying to find the
countless Diaries often by unknown
soldiers as they described this scene
Selden Connor a Union soldier from
Michigan who had arrived in Washington
only the day before was overwhelmed at
the sight of the gathering he wrote to
his mother there was a crowd
almost numberless maggi Linsley 24 had
been a supporter of the Union cause in
Nashville a few not shared by most of
her friends encountering the crowds
heading for the inaugural she wrote
later that day in her diary we were on
the edge of a great surging ocean of
humanity as visitors and residents
walked toward the Capitol they
encountered police on horseback
at every major intersection posters
ribbons medals tokens prepared for the
1864 campaign were visible everywhere
one poster from the election Shirley
summed up the fervent sentiments of many
arriving for the day's events all who
are opposed to a disgraceful armistice
with traitors Shirley Lincoln would
articulate these comments in his dress
one medal was inscribed a foe to
traitors while another read no
compromise with rebels and 1864 ribbon
capture the now clearly understood twin
goals of the war Union and Liberty well
what I'm trying to do is to bring us to
these dramatic events and to prepare us
for what Lincoln faced that day making a
quick transition when Lincoln was
introduced the crowd exploded in
expectation Noah Brooks correspondent
for the Sacramento Daily
Union describe the immense crowd like a
sea of heads as far as the eye could see
the throng looked like waves breaking at
their outer edges
Lincoln stepped from underneath the
shelter of the Capitol building out past
the Magnificent Corinthian columns at 56
he looked older than his years as
Lincoln rose he put on and adjusted his
steel-rimmed eyeglasses he held in his
left hand the inaugural address printed
in two columns Lincoln prepared to speak
now I'd like you to take that text again
into your hands and if I may I want to
suggest some of Lincoln's rhetorical
artistry his rhetoric his politics his
religion all fused together to make this
address so memorable as I suggested
earlier Lincoln begins in a way that is
not to catch our attention in the highly
charged atmosphere of wartime Washington
with soldiers everywhere it is if he
perhaps wants to lower expectations so
in line two if you look with me there is
less occasion for an extended address in
line eight little that his new could be
presented in line eleven the second line
from the bottom of the paragraph no
prediction in regard to it is ventured
he starts more like an observer than the
main actor the language of the first
paragraph is impersonal yes he uses the
pronouns I and myself but the ethos of
the first paragraph I suggest is
unemotional Lincoln directed the force
of his remarks away from himself by
speaking in a passive voice avoiding the
active voice sets up a paradigm that
Lincoln follows throughout his address
after this first paragraph he will use
no more personal pronouns Lincoln
dispenses one by one with the usual
contents of such an address in the first
sentence he says this is not the
occasion for an extended address in the
second sentence he reiterates why a
detailed statement was proper before but
not today he reiterates a detailed
statement was proper four years ago but
not today in the third
as he reminds the audience that many
other occasions they had had public
declarations on every point in phase
implying that he will not make such a
declaration today the audience surely
would have relished the
commander-in-chief giving a report on
the victories of Grant and Sherman but
he tells them a report on the progress
of arms he will not do that today
Lincoln begins by telling the audience
everything the speech is not and then he
concludes by suggesting that he will
make no prediction the problem is
Lincoln realized was the predictions had
been made all the way through the war
and again and again they proved to be
wrong predictions led to false optimism
there seemed to be nothing in this
beginning paragraph that had aroused the
passions of the audience in these
initial words Lincoln does not seem to
be building bridges to the Union
audience the audience is surely awaiting
for something more is he undercutting
the grand opportunity that he has at the
beginning of his second inauguration
after 32 years during which no president
has been reelected for a second term and
Lincoln can only muster at this second
appearing the text of the second
inaugural consists of 703 words five
hundred and five are of one syllable it
is the second shortest inaugural address
on record George Washington said in
effect thank you very much at a time
when there was not much tradition
Lincoln's pattern was to read his
addresses slowly he usually spoke not
more than 100 or 105 words a minute
at this rate even incorporating applause
of which there was only four times when
there was applause he's probably spoke
for only six to seven minutes I imagine
that people were still arriving as he
was concluding I want now to speak about
his strategy for his speech and call
your attention to four points in the
first two paragraphs the first point of
this speech is to somehow emphasize the
common convictions and the
common concerns of everyone in the Union
and so he starts out by emphasizing
common actions look in the second
paragraph where he uses the word all on
the occasion correspond you this four
years ago all thoughts were anxiously
directed all dreaded it all sought to a
verdict further on down he gives the the
word both parties deprecated war Lincoln
is beginning we may not fully understand
it yet to try to pull the nation
together by making us all a part of both
the problem and the solution what is the
word that just pulsates through that
second paragraph that really grabs our
attention he repeats it in every single
sentence it is the word war seven times
he uses the word war twice he uses the
pronoun it for war so that nine times he
offers this word what is he doing here
I'm suggesting that Lincoln himself is
aghast at the capacity of Americans to
inflict such damage on each other this
peace-loving nation has set itself upon
a task of brutality that is almost
understandable and Lincoln is suggesting
here that this war which begins as the
direct object grammatically and
historically of our concern and
attention becomes as the war progresses
the subject we are being carried along
by the war to his first two paragraphs
it's like reading a Shakespearean play
we may not understand the first act
until we get to the third act in his
chronicling the north the south the
soldiers the generals the president he
is suggesting that all of those who
thought they were in charge of the war
discover in fact that they are being
carried along by what one writer is
called this destructive war and then
Lincoln comes to the last sentence of
the paragraph and the war came I
pondered a long time how he said that
sentence and I'd like you to think with
me did he say it as the ending of the
paragraph is a great crescendo
with a dramatic voice and
the war came how do you think he said
that sentence anyone like to give a
reply
softly we don't have an audio we wish
that we did I imagine that he said it
sadly softly mournfully he was the
soldiers president he had internalized
into himself the pain and emotion of
these soldiers often he was up early in
the morning visiting soldiers in the
hospital general McClellan thought he
would secure certainly the soldiers vote
in the 1864 really election President
Lincoln secured 75% of the soldiers vote
I'm suggesting that his writing
transcends what he has done in previous
addresses certainly the first inaugural
and rises to the elegance of prose or
prose poetry let me suggest one reason
that I make this direction in the second
paragraph he uses the vehicle of
alliteration eight times he takes the
consonant D and repeats it again and
again and again on the occasion
corresponding to this four years ago all
thoughts were anxiously directed to an
impending Civil War all dreaded it all
sought to a verdict while the inaugural
address Lincoln was not a good speller
was he was being delivered from this
place devoted altogether to saving the
Union without war insurgent agents were
in the city seeking to destroy it
without war seeking you to dissolve the
Union divide effects by negotiation both
parties deprecated war now did Lincoln
set out to say in that second paragraph
I'm going to use alliteration no he uses
alliteration in the first inaugural -
what does alliteration do for us it
helps you and I the listener to organize
our thoughts to sense the symmetry of
his words it helps with a meter and the
pacing it carries us along this is part
of the beauty of Lincoln's rhetoric I
wish we could pause to ask to answer the
question that's often in the minds of
all of
how did Lincoln become such a marvelous
speaker in 1858 person who was writing
the history of Congress sent a
questionnaire yes there were
questionnaires in the 19th century to
everyone who had served in the House of
Representatives or the Senate and
Lincoln received that questionnaire one
person who received it sent back 22
pages of self-important answers Lincoln
sent back less than a page and when he
came to that question education I let my
historical imagination wander to those
who must have sat next to him in his one
term in Congress who were from Yale or
Harvard or other elite colleges Lincoln
wrote back one word an answer to that
question defective defective
I love the self deprecation that he
brings to his addresses if you turn the
page and start at the fourth line from
the top I suggest that when Lincoln
offers these words both read the same
Bible and pray to the same God and each
invokes his aid against the other he
embarks on a whole new territory in
inaugural addresses all my friends in
the Academy had said to me surely every
address before and every address since
will name the name of God and that
certainly is correct and so we can find
the words of Washington and Adams and
Jefferson each one but interestingly no
one except John Quincy Adams had ever
quoted the Bible before and Adams and
all of those other invocations it's
almost always in the last paragraph and
by the way we need God's help too but
Lincoln I'm suggesting is using
theological thinking here in a much more
profound way that is anchoring much of
his thoughts in 703 words he mentions
God
14 times quotes scripture four times
invokes prayer four times and to the
Protestant audience who is listening
they heard at least three or four other
intimations of scriptural allusion
notice though the way Lincoln deals with
religion he deals with it in a very
sophisticated way with different levels
of meaning both
the same Bible when the decision was
made to clear the ground at Gettysburg
to prepare for this dedicatory event in
November the 6000 bodies that were left
on the battlefield all of the things
were removed from their clothing and
catalogued so that members of the family
could come to get the jewelry the
notebook that whatever it was in on the
clothing
what chiefly survived were Bibles both
read the same Bible the American Bible
Society the flagship of over 300
voluntary associations that sprung into
being in the early 19th century the only
one remaining at the beginning of the
21st century printed over 5 million
Bibles the Confederate Bible Society
printed a couple of million - so every
soldier carried a Bible with him and
they couldn't carry a Bible of this size
so quickly they printed pocket Bibles
one of the most intriguing parts of my
research was to visit the American Bible
Society headquarters and to handle these
pocket Bibles Union and Confederate
often with words of inscription at the
beginning so at Lincoln's first level of
meaning he is affirming this use of the
Bible but he doesn't stop there he goes
on to say and each invokes his aid
against the other lincoln found himself
often in a difficult kind of lover's
quarrel with those who were religious i
think of lincoln somewhat like my
students at UCLA who would come up to me
again and again and say i am not
religious but I am spiritual well I'm
not sure if we say Lincoln was not
religious but he was theological or he
was spiritual but we've been put off by
the fact that he didn't join a church to
fail to recognize the deep theological
thinking that is taking place in his
addresses another reason we haven't
recognized it is that in his other
addresses you can go back and find the
antecedents in a whole train of
addresses so the house divided speech of
1858 doesn't just arrive you can see the
antecedents in previous speeches that is
much more difficult to do in Lincoln's
second inaugural and I argue that those
anti
scenes are often usually not in public
addresses but are in private
correspondence yes some of it was
published in interviews his wonderful
interview with the two wives of the
Confederate soldiers which he carried on
for three days with these two women in
the White House and then the wonderful
memo that he wrote only for himself that
was found after his death but what is
Lincoln doing here in his affirmation of
the Bible but also asking a question the
question is not in grammatical form but
I suggested is a question and each
invokes his aid against the other or a
couple of lines down the prayers of both
could not be answered clergymen had a
habit of coming to call on Lincoln and
one group came to see him and they said
I want you to know that we're so
delighted that God is on our side and
with that Lincoln threw up his hands and
stepped back and said I'm not at all
sure of that but I am certain that I
want to try to discover what it would
mean to be on God's side I believe that
Lincoln is speaking out against a tribal
god against a territorial god I found
myself writing before September 11 and I
wondered after I read the proofs if I
should keep it in but it's certainly
there in the epilogue Abraham Lincoln
speaks forever against any god Bless
America theology that fails to deal with
evil and hypocrisy in its own house
there is great courage in this remark
after he affirms the use of the Bible he
questions the use of the Bible he knows
that the Bible now in its authoritative
stance is being called into question how
can God be for and against the same
thing at the same time on sultry days at
the end of August 1862 Union and
Confederate forces clashed in a fierce
battle at Manassas Junction the small
railroad settlement on the main road
between Washington and Richmond thirteen
months earlier at the beginning of the
war the Union Army had been had suffered
a disastrous defeat at this same
Manassas in the north the battle was
called Bull Run
because of a small
during river several miles north now in
the summer of 1862 John Pope his troops
behind his back often called him
boastful Pope a West pointer who was
born in Illinois and raised at Kentucky
born in Kentucky and raised in Illinois
had been brought from the West and put
in charge of the army of Virginia in the
last week of August Stonewall Jackson
ever agam blur marched his 24,000 men
50 miles in two days to attack and burn
the Union stacks of supplies of an ASUS
then Jackson's troops disappeared
Pope reported that he had Jackson on the
run well I had all sorts of things in
here in my book on what the editors were
saying what the Diaries were saying in
my edit my editor at Simon Schuster
maybe take them all out it's part of the
anticipation this was surely going to be
the great victory that would turn the
tide of the war on the morning of August
29 Polk carried out attacks against
Jackson but the next day Robert Ely and
Jackson fell upon Pope in what North
called the Second Battle of Bull Run the
Union troops broke and gave ground all
the way back to their defenses on the
outskirts of Washington in five days of
fighting the Union forces of 65,000 men
had suffered over 16,000 casualties Lee
and Jackson's 55,000 troops had lost
fewer than 10,000 men this defeat was a
crushing blow to the north
amid the public hand wringing the most
public man in America convened a meeting
of his cabinet we've heard of attorney
general Bates this morning attorney
general Bates captured Lincoln's sombre
mood and his diary entry for that day he
writes the president was deeply
discouraged about the initial reports of
victory had turned in a news of defeat
and then he pens these words Lincoln
quote seemed wrung by the bitterest
anguish said he felt almost ready to
hang himself
that same day Lincoln put pen to paper
in a private musing a brooding president
strained to see the light in one of the
darkest moments of the war
this is what he wrote I'll never forget
the day I traveled to Brown University
to see this document in person
the will of God prevails in great
contests each party claims to act in
accordance with the will of God both
maybe and one must be wrong God cannot
before and against the same thing at the
same time in the present Civil War it is
quite possible that God's purpose is
something different from the purpose of
either party and yet the human
instrumentalities working just as they
do are of the best adaptation to affect
his purpose I'm almost ready to say this
is probably true that God wills this
contest and wills that it shall not end
by his mere quiet power on the minds of
the now contestants he could have either
saved or destroyed the union without a
human contest yet the contest began and
having begun he could give the final
victory to either side any day yet the
contest proceeds in approaching a second
inaugural address one surely needs to
contend with very very legitimate
questions was Lincoln speaking simply
what the audience wanted to hear was he
using biblical language because this was
the language of the people of that day
what other language was there to use I'm
arguing that this meditation on the
divine will this is the title that John
Hay gave to it when he discovered it
after Lincoln's death is the chief and a
Seaton that lies behind the second
inaugural no one knew about it the day
that Lincoln spoke so that when you take
your text in hand and Lincoln says the
Almighty has his own purposes I'm
arguing that that's the fulcrum sentence
of the entire address that Lincoln not
in any arrogant way is suggesting that
God is in is the primary actor not that
Lincoln knows how when where why but
that somehow in the chronology of the
first couple of paragraphs with all the
different actors Lincoln is now
suggesting that there is another actor
who is at work here in this war and
Lincoln's language for that actor is
what is significant he uses words
again and again he wills he wills he
uses the language the Living God in
approaching my topic I came to esteemed
biographers who again and again
described Lincoln as a fatalist fatalism
is a system where what is set in place
are immutable laws and you and I respond
to those laws somewhat as passive agents
is this who Lincoln really is well
certainly he was a fatalist he was a
skeptic as a young man my suggestion is
that Lincoln through the crucible of the
Civil War as Doris Kearns Goodwin
started to say this morning finds
himself in a much deeper place of
thought that the second inaugural is
almost his brooding almost his thinking
out loud and that one of the Forgotten
persons in this story is Phineas
Densmore Gurley the minister of the New
York Avenue Presbyterian Church here in
Washington Gurley a graduate of
Princeton seminary had been offered a
post at the seminary because he was
recognized as one of the great preachers
of his day but he stayed to be the
preacher to Lincoln and Lincoln unlike
his practice in Springfield began to
attend this church more and more
frequently though he had overtures from
other churches First Presbyterian Church
offered him a free pew right after the
inaugural address but those were new
school churches those were churches that
emphasized revivalism and emotionalism
Lincoln wanted a church that was
rational that was solid as he said about
girly-girl he doesn't talk about
politics and I've been able to place
Lincoln at at least three sermons where
we have the entire text of the sermon
and we have Lincoln present and one of
those sermons is the funeral sermon for
Willie and what is Densmore Gurley
preaching he's preaching old-school
Presbyterian Providence which he had
heard as a student from Charles Hodge
and so the suggestion here is that
Lincoln is moving in his thoughts and we
hear what we have to say is the
culmination of his thinking but it's
only the beginning of his thinking in
this second inaugural address well the
time is marching on especially after we
have started a little late so I think
I'm going to forgo some of what I wanted
to say but I want to return to the
question that you're going to answer why
then I've been going on
justing what a marvelous speech this is
and I would want to say that Lincoln in
his earlier speeches in the 40s and 50s
was very much a partisan speaker often
his speeches were filled with ridicule
with satire with bombast with barnyard
imagery but somehow when he becomes the
president his speeches begin to change
and that there's really light years
between the first inaugural and the
second inaugural but if so why is the
speech not popular would you like to
offer your opinion yes sir looks to me
like he's talking about slavery trust me
call the gun safe what about the right
to make contract or the right to own
property the basic rights of citizenship
is he walk away from this with this
words ballast for gun is he from ladies
he quit equating protecting the rights
of freed slaves without a very good
comment the comment is is Lincoln
perhaps not going far enough for the
radical abolitionists actually of course
some of the abolitionists began to
applaud Lincoln once the Emancipation
Proclamation is offered they began to
see him in a different light and in some
ways and I think our speaker William
Miller this morning would agree with
this that this is a very strong
statement about slavery and he makes the
statement about slavery which were not
really able to discuss this afternoon
right in the center of his remarks but
yes he does not discuss all of the
specific questions he has decided that
those specific questions can wait for
another day which he did not have as it
turned out today he offers something
quite different I would say that
Frederick Douglass on the day that
Lincoln was assassinated was sitting in
the community center in Rochester New
York he had not been invited to be one
of the three speakers by the mayor but
after those three white men spoke there
was a clamor that went up within the
audience
Douglas Douglas Douglas and Douglas was
invited to speak and as he got up the
very day that Lincoln was killed he
offered his own eulogy by reciting from
memory from memory the central portion
of the third paragraph of the second
inaugural address another question or
response why is the speech not
immediately popular yes perhaps people
were expecting soaring rhetoric and he
gave them common sense instead they were
expecting soaring rhetoric and he gave
them common sense instead was her hand
back here yes very short time and that's
very sad talks about the suffering of
the poor
because yes it is that the speech is not
triumphalist that it's solemn if not sad
it talks about the suffering that is
involved yes sir slavery is also
something else to make some clearances
before himself with the evils and and
that they are both the same sound it's
the Twitter
well there's a difference of opinion
between our first comment and that is
that Lincoln does something quite I
would say courageous both politically
and rhetorically where he suggests on
the great on the eve of this great
victory that there's an evil at the core
of the American Society that this evil
goes back 250 years and it's not
southern slavery he calls it American
slavery and he dares to suggest that
this is an offense before God just
ponder that for a while as to how
someone would have the courage to make
such a statement at the time in which he
spoke well you're doing what I
suggesting Lincoln does he never spoke
to an ideal audience he spoke to a real
audience and in the debates and other
things he was often found himself an
interchange let me just offer a couple
of the responses and then I will close
the New York Times the publisher of the
New York Times was the chairman of the
Republican Party and this is how the New
York Times responded he makes no boasts
of what he has done or promises of what
he will do he does not respond the
principles of the war does not read
eclair the worth of the Union does not
reproach I am an absolute submission to
the Constitution is the only peace now
those who work in the Civil War know
that the newspapers of that day were
even much more political than they are
today and so we probably should not be
surprised when the New York world says
it is with a blush of shame and wounded
pride as American citizens that we lay
before our readers today the inaugural
addresses of President Lincoln and Vice
President Johnson John Sellars I gave
you the title which the publisher didn't
use Lincoln's Sermon on the Mount and I
did so because right away this
Appalachian Sermon on the Mount became
attached to this address Frederick
Douglass who was in the crowd and who
was deeply disappointed in the first
inaugural but had now come to know
Lincoln had had visits with him in 1863
and 1864 he wrote in his journal for
that day this is not a state paper
this is a sermon and one of the most
intriguing comments which would have
been on the frontispiece with a
different title came interestingly from
the Daily Express of Petersburg Grant
was besieging Petersburg there were not
many newspapers still being published in
the south but on March 9th the Daily
Express of Petersburg obviously puzzled
wrote this response to the second
inaugural his allusions to almighty
power and his citations from Scriptures
might well become a preacher of
righteousness he seems to be thoroughly
imbued with reverence for the gospel of
peace and with faith and divine
revelation and then the writer goes on
not quite sure he once died think become
too positive we will refrain from
expressing our opinion saying with
lincoln who borrowed the idea and most
of the words from our saviors Sermon on
the Mount let us judge not that we be
not judged I can't resist concluding
however with these remarks the English
press got it immediately several people
have been saying to me this was an
English address not an American address
I'll let you wrestle with that one the
Saturday Review offered this comment if
it had been composed by any other
prominent American politician it would
have been boastful confident and
menacing but I liked the comment from
the spectator which using biblical
imagery concluded Lincoln quote seems
destined to be one of those foolish
things of the world destined to confound
the wise one of those weak things which
shall confound the things which are
mighty thank you very much
we're going to entertain one one
question from the audience
given the time lag that we're dealing
with and then I'm going to ask Michael
music to come up and introduce our next
speaker okay we'll take it a real
question from the audience just pick up
put up your hand I'm sorry go ahead you
reckon I didn't see ya
I planted that question in the audience
he suggests that or he makes the
statement well said that this second
inaugural address takes on the form of a
jeremiad jeremiad was a form that was
used by English and then especially
American Puritans it was the form taken
from the Prophet Jeremiah of identifying
those things within the society to which
God was holding the society in judgment
it might be natural phenomenon it might
be human phenomenon that quickly the
Puritans recognized that they were
losing the faith and vision of the first
generation and so by the third
generation you had this format of the
jeremiad it came back into being in the
nineteenth century both with the Second
Great Awakening and with the
abolitionists and so Lincoln I believe
yes Lincoln is really using here the
form of a jeremiad the slavery is the
American offense and how are we to
respond to this American offense and
therefore I argue the last paragraph to
the protestant audience there really
should have a therefore in it that the
first three paragraphs in the form of a
Protestant sermon are the indicative
what God has done and the last paragraph
is therefore what are we to do what are
we to do Lincoln is asking for
incredible acts of compassion with
malice toward none with charity for all
so yes the jeremiad I think is very much
in the background of this address
this event was part of the Abraham
Lincoln Institute fifth annual symposium
Lincoln's greatest speech is published
by Simon & Schuster and you can visit
Simon Says dot-com to get more